Es hat aber auch wirklich lange genug gedauert.
Das allererste Molekül des Universums wurde
jetzt gefunden, die erste Chemische Verbindung,
quasi überhaupt der Anfang der Chemie.
Ohne dieses Molekül gäbe es keinen Chemieunterricht,
und nicht nur weil es dann keine Chemie gäbe,
sondern weil auch wir nicht existieren würden.
Es ist der Beginn von allem und er wurde jetzt
gefunden.
Eine Sensation.
Clixoom Science & Fiction - Hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Science-Videos, abonniert den
Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr nichts - herzlich
willkommen!
Was ist wenn man weiß, dass es existieren
muss, aber es einfach nicht zu entdecken ist.
Für Wissenschaftler und Wissenschaftlerinnen
eine Horrorvorstellung.
Die Suche nimmt kein Ende, aber auch die Ungewissheit.
Haben wir uns geirrt?
Gibt es einen Denkfehler?
Ist alles ganz anders als gedacht?
So oder so ähnlich ging es der Wissenschaft
mit dem ersten Molekül, der ersten chemischen
Verbindung zwischen zwei Elementen.
Eigentlich musste sie irgendwo sein, aber
irgendwie war sie nicht zu finden.
Rolf Güsten vom Max-Planck-Institut für
Radioastronomie in Bonn dazu: „Die Chemie
im Universum begann mit Heliumhydrid.
Das Fehlen eines Nachweises dieses Moleküls
im interstellaren Raum hat die Astronomie
seit Langem vor ein Dilemma gestellt“ Aber
wie findet man ein solches Molekül im Weltall?
Dazu haben Robert Bunsen und Gustav Kirchhoff
Mitte des 19.
Jahrhunderts als 18hundert und die Spektralanalyse
erfunden.
Im Spektrum des Lichts, das von Nebeln oder
Sternen abgegeben wird, gibt es nämlich Unregelmäßigkeiten.
Und mit Ihnen kann man Elemente oder eben
Heliumhydrd finden.
Denn die Atome interagieren mit Licht und
verändern es.
Heliumhydrd war das erste Molekül im Universum.
Heliumhydrd oder HeH+.
Nach dem Urknall bildete sich zunächst, als
die Temperatur auf 4000 Kelvin fiel, Heliumatome
und diese reagierten dann mit Wasserstoffatomen,
die allerdings nur aus einem Proton bestanden.
Das Elektron fehlte noch.
Deswegen auch das H+ in der Formel.
Schon 1925 gelang es diese Verbindung im Labor
herzustellen, aber da wo sie eigentlich sein
sollte war sie einfach nicht aufzufinden.
Und das liegt am Licht, das von diesem Molekül
abgegeben wird.
Es hat eine Frequenz von zwei Terahertz und
entspricht damit einer Wellenlänge von 0,149
Millimetern.
Und das ist ziemlich schlecht.
Die Erdatmosphäre schluckt diesen Wellenlängenbereich
komplett.
Sprich: Mit Teleskopen hier auf der Erde ist
die Suche nach Heliumhydrd aussichtslos.
Deshalb muss aus dem Weltraum oder mit hochfliegenden
Observatorien gesucht werden.
Und genau das hat das Forschungsteam gemacht.
Sie haben das fliegende Observatorium SOFIA
eingesetzt.
In einer Flughöhe von 13 bis 14 km operiert
SOFIA oberhalb der absorbierenden Schichten
der unteren Atmosphäre.
„Mit den jüngsten Fortschritten in der
Terahertz-Technologie ist es nun möglich,
hochauflösende Spektroskopie bei den erforderlichen
ferninfraroten Wellenlängen durchzuführen”,
erklärt Rolf Güsten.
SOFIA befindet sich an Bord einer umgebauten
Boeing 747 und hat aus dieser Höhe den planetarischen
Nebel NGC 7027 unter die Lupe genommen und
wurde jetzt fündig.
Das erste Molekül des Universums.
Eine ziemliche Sensation.
Jetzt kann sich die Astrophysik viel besser
mit der Frühphase des Universums und insbesondere
den chemischen Reaktionen damals dort beschäftigen.
Chemische Bindungen einfach erklärt (X-Men)
- Cooles Video von Bytethinks - Draufklicken,
anschauen und auf jeden Fall bytethinks abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!